JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been
learning about critical points
of functions, how to find them
using the first derivatives
and how to classify them using
the second derivative test.
So I have a question
here for you about that.
So we have a function w.
It's a function of two
variables, x and y,
and it's given by this
polynomial function of them.
So w equals x cubed
minus 3xy plus y cubed.
So what I'd like you
to do is to first find
the critical values
of this function
and then classify
them-- are they
minima or maxima
or saddle points--
using the second
derivative test.
So why don't you
pause the video,
take some time to work that out.
Come back and we can
work it out together.
Hopefully, you had some luck
working out the solution
to this question.
Let's have a go at it.
So in order to find
the critical points,
we need to look at
the first derivative.
So the critical
points are the points
where both partial derivatives--
or all partial derivatives,
if we had a function of more
variables-- are equal to zero.
So we need to look at
the first partials.
So the first partials here, w
sub x, the partial with respect
to x-- well, it's
just a polynomial
so it's easy to compute
those partial derivatives.
It's going to be 3
x squared minus 3y,
and then the last term gets
killed because we treat y
as a constant, and so we want
that to be equal to zero.
And similarly, we want the
first partial with respect to y,
w sub y, to be equal to zero.
And so that's minus 3x
plus 3 y squared equals 0.
Now, luckily, these are
fairly simple equations,
so to solve them, we
could, for example,
take the first equation and we
could solve the first equation
for y in terms of x.
So that'll give us
y equals x squared.
And now if we plug
y equals x squared
into this second equation,
well, we get minus 3x plus 3 x
squared squared-- so that's x
to the fourth-- is equal to 0,
and we can divide out by
that 3, so that means minus x
plus x to the fourth equals 0.
Well, OK, so we could have x
equal to 0, or you can divide,
and then you get
x cubed equals 1,
and that has
solution x equals 1.
So x equals 0 or 1.
Those are the only
solutions to this equation.
And then the corresponding
y-values, well, we
know y is equal to x squared,
so this gives us critical points
when x is 0, y is 0,
and when x is 1, y is 1.
So this function has two
critical points: (0, 0)
and (1, 1).
Now we need to figure out
whether those critical points
are minima, maxima,
saddle points, sum
of several of those.
So in order to do
that, we're going
to use this nice
tool that we have:
the second derivative test.
So in order to apply the
second derivative test,
the first thing I need is
the second derivatives.
So let's compute them.
So the second-- let's
do the xx first.
So we take our first partial,
3 x squared minus 3y,
and we take another partial
of it with respect to x.
So that's, in this case,
that's just going to be 6x.
And then we've got the other
pure second partial, yy,
so we go back over
here, and we look
at what our first
partial w_y was,
and then we take another partial
of this with respect to y,
so that's just going to be 6y.
And then we have the mixed
partials w_xy and w_yx,
which, of course, are equal
to each other whenever
our function is nicely
behaved, like a polynomial.
So w_xy, we just take
the two mixed partials
and-- OK, so we take
the partial of w_x
with respect to y, for example,
and that gives us minus 3.
So these are our three partials,
and then often, we, you know,
call this one A and this
one C and this one B. I
guess I kind of mixed up the
order a little bit there.
So we look at these
three expressions,
and now we want to look
at what sometimes people
call the discriminant, although
I don't know if Professor
Auroux used that term.
So we want to study what the
expression A*C minus B squared
is, so we want to know is this
positive, is this negative?
At the critical points.
So at the critical
points, right?
This is important.
At the critical points.
So let's do the
point (1, 1) first.
So at (1, 1), we have A is equal
to-- well, we put in x is 1,
y is 1 into the expression for
A here, and that just gives a 6.
We put x 1, y 1 into
the expression for C,
and that also gives
a 6, we put x 1, y 1
into the expression for B,
and that gives us minus 3.
So A is 6, B is minus 3, C is 6,
so A*C minus B squared is equal
to, well it's equal to
36 minus 9, so that's 27.
And, in particular,
it's positive.
So when this is
positive, that means we
either have a
maximum or a minimum.
So in order to
figure out whether we
have a maximum or a minimum,
we check the sign of A.
So in this case, the
sign of A is positive.
A is a positive number.
So when you have that A*C minus
B squared is positive and A is
positive, that means
you have a minimum.
So the critical point
(1, 1) is a local minimum
for this function.
All right.
Now we can do the same thing
for the critical point (0, 0).
So recall A was
6x, so at (0, 0).
A is equal to 0, B was equal
to negative 3 everywhere,
and C was equal to
6y, so at (0, 0),
that's 6 times 0
so that's also 0.
So then our quantity that we
want to look at, A*C minus B
squared, well, that's
0 times 0 minus 9,
so that's equal to negative 9.
And negative 9 is less than 0,
so when A*C minus B squared is
less than 0, that means
we have a saddle point.
So in this case, the
second derivative test
was able successfully
to distinguish
what kinds of critical
points we had,
and it found that the first
critical point 1, 1 was
a minimum and that the
second critical point
0, 0 was a saddle point.
So just to quickly rehash what
we did, we had a function.
Back over here, we started
with this function w.
We had a nice formula for it.
We computed its
first derivatives.
We set them both equal
to zero and we solved
that system of equations.
So we found two solutions
to that system of equations,
and those two solutions
are the critical points,
the points where both partial
derivatives are equal to zero.
So when you have the
two critical points,
then you want to apply
the second derivative test
to figure out for
each critical point
whether it's a saddle point,
a minimum or a maximum.
So we took our two
critical points, (1, 1)
and (0, 0), and at those
points, we evaluated
the second derivative.
So A is the xx
second derivative.
B is the mixed partial w_xy, and
C is the yy second derivative.
So we evaluate those expressions
at the points in question,
and then we look at
A*C minus B squared.
And then the sign of A*C minus
B squared, if it's negative,
that gives us a saddle point.
If it's positive, that gives us
either a maximum or a minimum,
and we check which
one by looking
at the sign of A. So
here A was positive,
so we got a minimum at (1, 1).
So I'll stop there.